hey all attended couch here and this tie
you Tuesday video I'm actually not gonna
go over this week's tech Tuesday
I'm data set which is about
african-american achievements instead I
actually got a comment asking me if I
could do a video on forecasting models
specifically ARMA or autoregressive
moving average models and I figured I
would just kind of look over some
popular packages and kind of go over a
kind of a high-level overview of these
popular timeseriesforecasting package in
are just with recent events I kinda want
her to talk about I guess African
Americans and their representation in
tech so currently there's a bunch of
protesting about the systematic
injustice against African American
specifically with police brutality and
although I don't have a huge platform I
thought it'd be interesting for me to
kind of talk about just for a few
minutes um especially as someone who is
a person of color who lives in the
Midwest which is a predominantly white
area I think it's one thing that I
noticed when I was in my classes both in
computer science and business classes as
is that there was actually a decent
model representation among Asian
Americans among white Americans however
there weren't a lot of African Americans
so um I was looking it up on I guess
Brookings and I saw that they had an
article about black and Hispanic on a
representation in tech and basically um
there is a huge problem in the tech
industry with black and Hispanic or
Latino representation and I think it's
kind of important to be aware of this
even though I'm sure many of you guys
are very inclusive and are not trying to
uh you know exclude these minorities but
it's something to be you know it's kind
of a food for thought thing so if you
see someone kind of talk to him about it
talk about how it's even or it's a
problem everywhere it's problem in tech
and you know maybe we can add some
positive change so I just wanted to
bring this bring that up a little short
a little short a little excerpt if you
guys are protesting you know bring a
friend wear a face mask and try to stay
safe
okay so now that we're actually on time
series stuff um one thing that I can't
wanted to show you guys is that so there
is an actual lot of classes on time
series data there's not a lot of stuff
on time series data that's one of the
main reasons why Facebook's profit
package came out is they realize many
people out of school or even outside of
grad school do not have a lot of
experience with time series analysis and
forecasting so I thought well let's see
what resources we do have one thing I
think everyone should be really aware of
is that you can access a lot of these
graduate level classes and kind of look
over at least the slides and the the
lecture notes that they give up
especially um Ivy League level
colleges or public Ivies or you know
California colleges many of them will
have to post their entire curriculum and
you can kinda just go over and kind of
just go at your own pace and see what's
going on so for me I spent the weekend
just kind of looking at um UPenn um so
basically warren school of businesses
time series classes and i actually most
of my stuff came from the introduction
to time series analysis which is
actually a part of an insurance class
okay and this is the lecture that
actually I've got it from I'll put the
links in description below and you guys
can go over it but I just wanted to show
you what our autoregressive or ARMA
models as a combination between auto
regressive models and moving average
models okay so I'm gonna open up our and
we're gonna do this we're gonna do a you
know a short little overview of the ARMA
models okay so I'm gonna do this tidy
Tuesday armed arma models cool okay okay
and then instead of having the actual
tidy models package I'm actually gonna
look up load up the tidy verse the model
data package which comes from the tidy
models package and also going to load up
the forecast
package so the forecast package was the
original like package for most
forecasting however now it's depreciated
and people actually use the fable
package so the fatal package is actually
the successor to it but when I was
looking at it I saw that that our
command check is failing so they might
be changing some things so I figured I
would just kind of go with the og
forecasting package and just do
forecasts okay so we're gonna do that
so with the model data it actually comes
with a bunch of data sets so we're gonna
first float in the chicago data set so
i'm when i until load that and you just
use the data command and it will
automatically load it so we have this
this kind of this data frame or whatever
it's 550 600 rows with 50 columns and
when I was looking at the actual data
dictionary in the model data PDF you
know overview thing they had just a
short description of the chicago data
set and the main idea is that they're
trying to predict El train ridership
with all these features and these
features right here are called are the
actual Chicago station names that
actually lagged features so there's a
preview last 14 days or the the last two
week I think like two weeks ago that was
that the average ridership or whatever
like that they also contain like
temperature data when data precipitation
just like overall weather stuff and
usually they also have these on one hot
encoded I guess like no these at dummy
variables of sports stuff so if the
Blackhawks are playing they're probably
to see more like activity in the trains
if they're a way then they're probably
giving less so we have that those type
of features we're really not gonna use
any of these features but we will
probably revisit this and do some more
predictive modeling stuff in the future
which will be a much which will be more
complex black box modeling
but what we're really gonna use is
ridership and data and data ad ridership
and date so that's what we're gonna do
okay so when we do Chicago I'm gonna do
select ridership and date what we're
gonna do is want to plot this out assume
like okay so that's what we have here so
one main thing with ARMA models is that
we're actually trying to predict a data
that is called stationary data so what
is stationary data well stationary data
basically assumes that the average of
whatever value were trying to predict in
this case we're trying to predict
average ridership we're trying to
predict ridership and we're saying the
average ridership value should be the
same it is not changing so we when we
look at this we can see that there's a
huge band there's a bunch of noise on
the not there's better noises watch
seasonality issues but if we look at it
we it looks kind of the same so I bet if
I do a we could do like a yearly or
monthly average let's let's see what we
can do I'm gonna actually load up the
was it the Bluebird a package so that
way we can do more date work okay so
this is just kind of like a general EDA
for how we're gonna approach this
forecasting problem so we're gonna say
need to clean up and evaluate the time
series components okay now we're gonna
do this in tight reverse first the
forecast package actually has some
little helper functions but we should
just do it just gain some intuition okay
so we're gonna do is uh when a I'm gonna
select Chicago and I'm gonna assign it
to Chicago okay
so it's this so Chicago
we're gonna we're gonna add some
features we're gonna say Mutai
month equals month date and this in in
this case it's that was it the number I
I don't want that I want the we want we
might want to get the name too so all
the month dot abbreviation I believe
it's a list so I can do that
just a little inclusion with our so now
we have it instead that the number we
have the month so we're gonna do that
so I'm gonna I'm gonna name this month
name and then we'll say month equals
month okay oh okay
month date okay we're also going to add
a year feature some once a year he goes
to your date okay so now let's now let's
revisit so ggplot KS x equals date y
equals beer and we'll say color equals a
year actually we'll do a white Gulf
ridership and when then we'll do giome
wine oh and we I gotta mutate aspect so
mutate year he goes as a factor here
okay oops and then screw that up to
month there we go
so what are we seeing here we're seeing
that there actually is some seasonality
maybe I could do a Geum
smooth and then se equals false okay
what are we seeing so we can see that
ridership is increasing and then it's
kind of like a hump right so it's like
it's getting more popular maybe like the
the midsummer fall and then starts
decreasing around the winter periods
which makes sense alright great so we
see that there's some seasonal issues
right and what we want to do is what we
want to do is actually kind
look at and kind of compensate for this
so that's what it's forecasting is
mainly used for so forecasting when
people think about forecasting they
think it's kind of a very sexy way of
like predicting years and years in the
future using these crazy models when in
reality we really want to control the
time component and just predict the
values so when what we're doing with the
forecasting is we're basically saying
that we want to account for any
time-dependent interactions and then
just focus forecast that overall trend
so when we go to a Chicago we're gonna
convert this to a time series object
okay I'm gonna stop that and what we're
gonna use is the MS TL which is
basically it what it says is a
decomposes it where it's basically a
helper function to base to get the
trends and all the time and basically
all the adjustments to it so we're gonna
use the auto plot which comes with the
forecast package and here's here's what
we get so what it's saying is okay so
here's our here's our raw data here's
the overall overall trend we're seeing
that's actually increasing and then we
have these values when we do the EF fig
that height fig hi it equals 15 so we
have a trend we have our output of
trying to ridership we have what kind of
date and then we have the remainder of
remainders of it that it can't account
for so there's some stuff that I can't
account for cool so we're also gonna do
is what's let's convert this back let's
let's use another helper from it and
what we can do is I wouldn't do that and
then we can do the ggs t just gdts oops
you got to select so saying that of GG
time series displays only for univariate
time series so we're just going to
select the
a ridership ridership convert that to a
time-series object and then use the GG
time series display alright so now we
have this we have what is our data I
believe and then we have these other
things which are Auto correlation
functions and partial auto correlation
functions so what does that mean a big
thing with time series is understanding
whether this dip this data has
correlation with the previous data so
when we think about correlation we think
of correlation between columns right
entry there columns
however autocorrelation is correlation
between rows so that's what it's trying
to do and what this says right here is
that we have our x axis which is lags
and then we have our y axis which is the
auto correlation and partial auto auto
correlation functions what it's saying
is it's comparing it to the previous lag
variables okay and what do we see here
is we see this kind of a was it little
like wave right and that's something
where we can say okay this is a very
specific trend these lagged or these are
these this data is heavily correlated
has all a ton of auto correlation okay
same with P partial auto correlation
functions what this does is it tries to
account for these seasonal changes and
it still find some more correlation but
it kind of dampens down we can see some
damping effects so how do we fix this
what when we see this we might think
that okay well maybe well maybe this
this mean this average this average
ridership is actually non-stationary so
how can we change this data into a
non-stationary data one way to do this
is instead of predicting instead of
predicting the value we can we can
predict the difference in values which
is called a differencing okay so right
here we can see there's a huge teasel
trend and then in and if we change to a
weekly change
we can see that there is a stationary
relay station er the data becomes
stationary when this converts it to
basically an ARMA model to a ARIMA model
okay so let's do it so we look at this
data we can actually use the mutate
function and we can say ridership daily
change and that will equal to ridership
- and then we can add actual we can use
the tiburce and use I believe the lag
ridership and then one and then we can
also do just a SAN each I can say okay
well look lagged writer ship equals lag
ridership one all right so ridership
15.3 250 0.732
the change is point O 3 so we we know
that our lagged variable or our
differencing has worked so we're gonna
say we suspect a non-stationary data
data set suspect we suspect this data is
non-stationary so we will try using
different saying okay so when we look at
this we can do GG plot I close writer
was it ridership yep
daily change plus GM 1 okay and what do
we see here a much better picture even
though it's a very clunky we can see
that there is way less of a train but
less of a change when compared to say
this one where we can see there was an
upward momentum into an increase so one
thing that we could say with this time
series component whereas an increase in
ridership
it's a good say that okay well Chicago
has probably spent increasing and a
population and we could just do a
control for population and then the
ridership will go into a stationary
state that I am see for this stuff I
would probably say okay we can do a time
series when your model and I start
messing with that however I'm gonna
focus mostly on the forecast package and
on ARMA models okay
so so when we see this we can see that
ok well this this is starting to look
good so we're gonna start actually doing
the ARMA model but we want to do some
more plotting on it ok so in this case
we're going to use the we're going to
select your cago we're gonna use the
chicago data set select a date and
ridership daily change convert that to a
time series and then then plot out the
what the hell Oh yep and then plot out
using gggg times your display okay so
what do we see here still there is some
there is still some stuff going on we
can still see that there's some
autocorrelation but this could be an
actual seasonal component instead of an
actual moving it's non stationary data
so let's let's let's find out the
differences that we did in the previous
chunks right here using the MSE oh okay
so Chicago select date and right writer
do change
throw in a time series throwing that
oops throwing that and then we'll do the
auto plot
okay so it created a basically found the
trend the trend is very miniscule we can
see at zero a more of a negative trend
you know okay and then we can have the
remainder that we can we can try to try
to fix okay so when we actually do these
um do these uh forecasting we can we can
kind of look at it we can look at what
ways we can do this so with the forecast
package look is that forecast package we
have a ton of different things we can do
okay a lot of it is just kind of helper
functions to do some post hoc analysis
on it or some pre analysis on it but the
main functions that we're gonna probably
use is the auto are Rema function will
basically tune the primers for us okay
additionally they have other algorithms
so they have the are fema they probably
have was it the bats yeah the the be ats
model and they also have I think they
also have like a neural network in there
let's see where is it yeah okay it was a
sto know
I don't know so they used i pressure
that veneer on that working in but what
we're actually to use is the auto or
Rima so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna i'm going to select the right
airship do is change we're gonna do a
quarter to eight time series and we're
gonna do the auto or yuma function so we
run that we can look at our auto ARIMA
results and it created an ARIMA model
with three with the primers 3 comma 0
comma 3 so the main parameters between
it I believe it is PDQ so what it's
saying is it's using one two and three
Auto regressive parameters and want to
use three moving averages and these are
all I galactic features so it's saying
okay we're gonna use like the previous
day the second previous day and the
third previous day as features we're
also going to use the first the average
second moving average they're moving
average okay so once we do that we can
also use the forecast function and you
know give us a nice little interval of a
future change it future predictions we
can also throw that into the auto plot
and you can see it these are the
predictions that's making alright so one
thing that you need to realize with
let's here I think it's a cute one right
we can do that one thing with the yeah
so one thing with the forecast and arma
models is that the the longer or the
more drawn-out forecast so if you're
trying to forecast a no longer in the
future in a longer period of time the
more likely it's gonna regress to the
mean and what that means is if you're
say trying to make a forecast say a
three years I have three years in the
future what its gonna do is it's gonna
start regressing or it's gonna just
predict a zero because most of the ARMA
models
[Music]
most on the are my models parameters is
just using previous data and just kind
of averaging it okay so let's do this
what we're also gonna do is we're gonna
test out some other ones so when we take
the Chicago data set o data it's it well
we can also do is we can use a the ETS
function which is Katy yes which is
basically a smoothing model okay which
is basically which is a component of the
ARMA model in this case the the
smoothing parameter or the smoothing
part of it is the AR part so if we do
the forecast and an auto plot we see
it's still producing the same thing
roughly the same thing okay
let's here we can also kind of show how
we can kind of also work with non
stationary data so if you see in the
past oh I don't think I didn't invest so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna load
up a much sparser dataset so what we're
gonna do is the oil in the drinks data
set so drinks and this is bassy
um I guess monthly alcoholic beverage
sales compiled from the st. Louis Fed so
I'm gonna do some renaming so rename and
so sales equals do and what we can do is
we need to convert this straight into a
time series and we can do like was that
the what function is that call that yeah
news and we can do the GG TSS play
select sales okay
and we can select the sales and what we
can do is we can kind of look at this
it's right here we know that is the it
is non-stationary
and we see this help me out there's a
decent mount of autocorrelation both on
the autocorrelation function and also on
the partial autocorrelation function
however there is comic a spike right
here and then it starts to reduce okay
so we're doing this um what we can do is
also look at was it the was it we can we
can also look at the MS CL so if we go
to drinks select sales TS and SEL and
auto plot it oops auto plot when you see
that it's removing the trend and now we
kind of have a a non-stationary thing
we're trying to predict okay so what
happens if we actually try to do some
non stationary forecasting we're using
in our remove model okay and we'll just
see let's just see what happens so we're
gonna do drinks select sales and then
time series and we do look at auto dot
ARIMA we see zero one and one okay and
then we can do a forecast and what we're
trying to forecast say let's try to
forecast the next three months and auto
plot it wait see is trying to predict
the average with some nice confidence
intervals I'm great
so that's we see it for the for the ARMA
sections again armored models are
actually pretty straightforward however
there's a decent amount of actual visual
analysis and season and DC's D trending
the actual data so one thing that I
thought would be interesting also to
work with is looking at a a part of the
insurance time series analysis using
linear models so if we go back to here
we can see it that they actually have a
regression models for time series all
right what they're trying to do is do
what the ARMA model is doing however try
to fix it and one thing that we can do
is kind of show how how we can do
transformations okay so that's what
we're do we're gonna do on the sales
data for the drinks data and what we can
do is we can do a mutate and say sales
equals log 10 log log sales I think it's
because o it is a log 10 log 10 sales
actually will say a log 10 sales equals
sales and we then we can do a GG plot x
equals day y equals sales plus a jam
line pushing them line and they say y
equals a log 10 sales ohh
ooh actually maybe I should do a gather
so key equals key value equals value
nice day and then we can do a y equals
value color equals key and we'll get you
a facet wrap key scales equals 3y here
hmmm what's going on here
up there you okay so we did a simple
transformation let's see how it affects
the actual forecast okay so what we're
gonna do is we're going to select this
again select sales TS it and then which
to an auto got ARIMA and this will be
our regular ARIMA right and now we're
gonna do our logged ARIMA model so
drinks select sales mutate sales equals
log 10 sales and then ts auto da arena
okay
and now it's a compare them where you
going
arena and I'm gonna say it wasn't
blogged hurting about actually I'll just
put it bear right there
okay so what's what's kind of
interesting about this is we can see how
on the ARIMA models have different
parameters now even though we just did a
basic log10 transformation the models
are very different for example the rig
or even model doesn't use any smoothing
or a our models however uses a moving
average whereas the hog during but uses
a bunch of smoothing specifically 1st
and 2nd order autoregressive models ok
what else can we do so what we can do is
we can kind of show some adjustments so
what they do is they actually use the
lag residuals in this case we're going
to use a we're gonna use a linear model
for this so that's what we're gonna do
so now what we're gonna do is kind of
transition to not just transformations
but using linear models to to do basic
regression stuff in this case I believe
with linear regression models we must
have we must assume a non stationary
let's zero initial linear trend post a
stationary data but simply that but I
think since we have since is saying that
our trend is should be easy to forecast
and we look at our drinks we be
comfortable and say that okay well we
can say that the trend can be forecasted
using a basic growth thing right and
that's kind of showing right here with
the log10 of sales ok so instead we're
gonna be eight a time column so we'll
say time and that will equal to row
number okay now we're gonna select time
and sales and actually load up the broom
package
okay and we're gonna call this our model
data cool ooh actually I'm not gonna do
that
okay swear model data as sales and then
we're gonna okay so we have our model
data I'm gonna add some features just so
we can throw in some dummy variables so
I'm gonna say mutate a month month
equals month abbreviation month and then
date
all right ooh go wrap that right so now
I have our month and then we're gonna
stick with that yeah so yeah we'll stick
with that so ggplot no we're going to
select the time month and sales and
we're gonna throw in a linear model so
linear model and this in this case we're
gonna predict sales as a function of
time and in a month
time cannot course mmm what can i course
class for my to ID data equals dot there
you so we have this you can see how it
created let's here I created a dummy
variable let's count it out 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 so it's doing the dummy
variable so all these things are
relative to the one that's being omitted
I want to see which ones actually being
emitted January February March April so
April is the one being omitted well so
one thing that we can actually do is we
can assign this and we'll
a forecast linear forecast so now we
have an actual model object what's cool
about the Broom package is we can
actually do some basic tidy tidying on
it so we can say tidy linear forecasts
and now I have all the estimates right I
just you know what we can do is we can
do a glance and we can kind of look at
the the main things like that we can
also do is augment it and this is the
thing we wanted so what we have is the
predictions for all of our observations
but what we also have is our residuals
okay so in this case what we're gonna do
is we're going to actually add the
residuals or the lagged residuals as a
feature okay we don't slip visualize our
residuals so we're gonna we should just
do that first so ggplot AS x equals time
y equals dot standard diapers in the
genome point right and we can see that
there is a pattern emerging from our
residual analysis right where it's kind
of trying to produce this value and on
the tail ends it's uh overestimating it
okay so say looking at the residuals
okay so we're gonna scroll this back in
so now we have these things what we can
do is we can actually do a week we can
we can add these things into our lag
residuals so that's what we're gonna do
so we're gonna select the time and dot
standardized dot residuals and we're
gonna call it
residuals bridge
Jules patrols that so that's our
residuals and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna add we're gonna do a little
we're gonna basically do a join on it
alright so we have this we're gonna do a
left join using this and once a by
equals C time equal oh actually would
you say time equals time
so we have our residuals but we can't
that that can cause some data leakage
right and we don't want to do that so
we're gonna do a mutate and we'll say
lagged residuals equals up lag residuals
and we're gonna do it for one period
right so we have last month's residuals
obviously the first month will not have
residuals and we'll do a drop na so
we're gonna do this model oops model
data with rigid right and we're gonna
create our new model so this case we're
gonna say model with always it called we
said a linear or cast with rigid or zid
and we'll do a linear model using oops
yeah with vs so we're gonna use we're
gonna predict sales as a using time
month and the lagged rigid flagged
residuals the data will equal to Oh
model data
cool now all we have that we can
evaluate and compare both models so we
have our linear forecast with residuals
we can also do a basic summary of it
right and we can analyze our p-values
for example July is not statistically
significant also and our September is
not not statistically significant that's
kind of interesting um however we really
can't remove it because it is a function
of our months additionally what we can
see is our actual lakh residuals are
statistically significant which means
that we can kind of say okay that's fine
we should actually keep this feature
into it because it must improve our
model performance but when actually
comparing models so if we look at our
whole linear forecast submarine we also
look at the p values and we can see the
same thing where these guys are less it
are still not statistically significant
but if we do some tidying where we do a
say oops
tidy actually can do stew what is it a
glance and then we can say mutate model
equals R is it'd and then we can add
this guy and I know R is it and it's to
our pine
we can do a gather key equals key value
equals value minus model right and then
we can evaluate it pretty well so x
equals model y equals value plus column
plus facet wrap key scales equals three
and we'll throw in a fill equals um was
it model cool so what are we seeing here
there's not a huge difference between
these models okay but I'm gonna look at
this thing instead oh we look at this so
um charts show a a small diff between
models but if we look at say let's hear
their AIC and bi SI scores we can see
the one with residuals does improve the
B I see an AIC scores where you want the
lower AIC or bi C okay so how can we
improve this model what let's kind of
add in a transformation so that's what
we're gonna do
so let's let's add a transformation okay
in this case I'm actually gonna go back
grab this say blog forecast with
residuals and this in this case we ran
out take a log I'll log 10 of sales now
let's look at the transformation
okay so interesting we can also do a a
grant okay we have our log residuals
okay so we have that interesting okay so
when I'm actually comparing these two
models so we have our logged model and
also our linear model we actually kind
of have to do we actually have to do
some Corrections rename log what sales
equals one
okay there we go we need it okay and
then mute a sales equals 10 to the power
of sales arey
there we go okay and then we can do a
lagged what dot fitted equals 10 ^ dot
fitted and looking evaluate okay so then
we could say mutate was it how how
should we do it mean absolute error so
mean absolute error so absolute error
equals absolute time sales - dot dot
fitted
one mutate error equals sales minus dot
fitted okay and then absolute of that
and then we'll take the average so mean
of error and then say na de RM equals
true Oh summarize summarize how many
equals mean error okay and then we can
do this so mutate error equals absolute
of sales - not fitted summarize ma
equals mean error and we'd see that our
mean after error is a little bit lower
using the log linear forecasting with
residuals I know that was a little quick
I'm sure I'm gonna clean up this video
and kind of remove a lot of meat going
through it but I kinda want to do a kind
of a quicker video and kind of show this
step is kind of like learning a new data
science concept and kind of showing guys
about forecasting methods so I'll see
you guys next week and I tell you on